Mình dùng tả lời ảnh bác là bản công có có một đẹp thêm gia sách,
để kênh anh ấy qua lại.
Tuy nhiên, bạn cũng đừng quá lo đáng vào buồn khi mà
thử dụng thay và nó thật ra các bạn là bữa kết định.
Nếu các bạn là bữa kết định,
nó cũng có một phần tên nhẹ.
Nên chính vì vậy, nếu như mà em còn đặc tứng được những cái điều kiện như là
nếu như là nguld thách sách tự nhiên là bà.
Khi thế gián được hơi là đồng thời chắc kết.
Chắc kết kết kết tự nhiên mà đặc tứng được chắc tự chí thấy quy định của nha,
nguld thách.
Tại vì em vẫn có thể cần nhát bằng những cái vươi thức này khi em,
tham gia sách tự nhiên, đúng một quy định của chương nào mình thành đối với ngần đi qua.
Nói ta như một tí của em.